ぐっちょぐじゅじゅんってみた今日者で枚全て愛するの帯締めが出来ました
わーっドライアイスだった
配牌格ゲーば売ってる3 t まで使えば前者に金で買ってきました
俺多分やっぱり1いきたいと思うんですね分かんないってください youtube 見
てないもんサーティーワンアイス機でも全書に混ぜる
[音楽]
割れちゃってる人いました
wh
めっちゃ目のやってんじゃそれも一人ところじゃないずびっくりするぐらいいろんな人
をやってますねちょっとウォッチ日かちゃって皆さんが大きく強ところ入ってます
こちら10種類32種類この中には当然ていなかった
米全部フレーバーを追われていますそれは何かと言いますとあんなに校舎を
プロデュースした米政府のフレーバーが入っているので昔思ってただけでいえば32は
なくても出る末でみたらどんな子になるとみたいですと違う味になってもね
ブレイザーに使われたりとジャニコロさんありがとうございます
強欲な壺普通にみんなやってて普通には泣いています
[音楽]
なんでも買っちゃったら仕方ないんでやりまあまで来たら普通にねもう美味しいやつを
作りたい全然が解明していきましょう
[音楽]
終わりまーすみんなとネタが被っているが全然違いますなぜならこのフレーバーの中身
は何頃にが作ったか2位
レモンハニーが入っているので味は絶対変わってますフレーバー日疲れたけど全然味の
寒ニュアンスが違ってくるんで普通に食べたんですけど我慢して混ぜますぞやあ
もう混ぜる様の要求を買ってきたので補足する creema そうだ
web サベトン
サビは love chocolate レジベルナトピンクとキャンディー
ラズベリープロ birds 安眠豆腐6万弱レザーハイスクールがあっ
大事な
love ポーズを取っています
舐めるちゃうよいい抹茶
つよね本当にと絆ので端折ります
[音楽]
まあ結構やっぱかなくになりますねさあこっからまずで4勝
まず凄い凄い原宿待って本当に何かちょっと待って
受けてんなまあ色がもうつべさんとねほんとちょっとシャッフル社員ですよね
ません
これだとたぶんちょっと交流ねそうになっちゃうねちゃんと満足度にミキサー使えます
合成頑張ってるプーすごいは2ゲイめっちゃ混ざってるけど戻ってきました
結構いい感じです
[拍手]
ううううううっ
ブルー
me
う s 2型めっちゃもう右たら使った100倍はなりましたただギロ的な話をすると
完全にチョコですね戦ではとりあえず一口だけ食べてみましょう見た目は超ですね
ん me
ええええええ
島の街バル初めてっ
[音楽]
ん
みんなあーてくれー
一つすごいクって何味かどうする
0バダ美容ヴェルニ
うん
[音楽]
me
うううう
バッハ
なんてっ
ビオフェルミン見上げるにポロリやいいんだよ
スプレー車